what's it like uh meeting and hanging
with Nas oh man he he a king man a
soldier man shout out Nas my [__] know
uh give my utmost respect man my highest
regards he like he He Man Nas is Like he
he is he just like he Nas my [__] you
can't like you meet another [__]
he's not that dude you know what I'm
saying like I didn't know Nas you know
what I'm saying but but however I seen
Naas and however he portrayed himself
that's how blood was when I met him you
know what I'm saying it wasn't no
different from the movie [__] to
[__] uh from belly that belly [__]
you feel me that was the realest [__] oh
God yeah yeah my [__] you know him and
X was off that [__] but U but um so he
he didn't disappoint n he a real one
were you able to like kind of chop it up
up with him about like just kind of like
cuz I feel like what what your son has
done with nas is is unprecedented lowkey
you know what I mean like I feel like
uh I I mean Nas just do this [__] man
cuz it's in his heart it's in his soul
that's a part of him my [__] like a
athlete he like bouncing the ball [__]
is nothing for real so yeah and like
that Grammy is like a big deal the
Grammy that they won that's like uh
that's got that's like you know
obviously shout out to hit he not like
it's his only Grammy but like that
Grammy to me I like was like it had to
have meant so much cuz it was with Nas
and it was like years after his initial
run you know what I'm saying yeah so man
they man took him a long time to break
him off man they should have been gave
Nas's flowers for sure man you know what
I'm saying talk to me man just like
about you uh what what first of all uh
how long have you been rapping and give
me kind of like some of your background
like like what part of Cali are you from
you know what I'm saying like how long
have you been making music cuz you're
you're like the OG you know what I'm
saying I'm sure you you had a lot of the
you know inspiration as to why he ended
up taking his career path to where it
was yeah I mean I grew up [__] with
the old school you know what I'm saying
the the uh the krs1 the biz Marky the
[__] you know back to Uncle Jam's
Army type [__] but um but yeah I'm from
Pasadena PDL shout out to Pas y w city
of roses and um yeah I just been I've
been spitting all my life for real just
Clowning with it though I never you know
what I'm saying it was just a part of me
like I say it something you just breathe
it was like yeah I always did it and
clowned with it and you know [__]
always say oh that's tight but I never
took it serious you know what I'm saying
what was the closest you had taken it to
like obviously prior to the hs87 wave
when when you were on grinding all my
life and all that but was there like a a
earlier era where you were close to kind
of like putting out music or or being
like more of a serious artist where you
were kind of like considering n that was
the only time I really you know what I'm
saying was uh Ser cuz I was fresh out
and have a chance been in jail [__]
before that it was just like a hobby
yeah I me just spitting you know was
young little you know what I'm saying
just kicking it clowning with with
friends but um other than that just
remixing [__] right know he was remixing
I was remixing way back then just
jumping on Beats yeah jumping on Beats
and redoing the same [__] like Bobby
Jimmy did that roaches mhm look at all
these roaches that [__] yeah just
Clowning [__] like that but uh yeah
Pasadena is a city that uh doesn't get a
lot of recognition or love when we think
about La no we underrated my [__] and I
love Pasadena it's one of my favorite
cities to go to to get food and TR sets
my [__] oh God what do you mean by that
I mean [__] we set the tone my [__] on
a lot of [__] on [__] that's that's said
it my [__] like NOP it all that [__]
you know I'm saying going say like what
do what do you think it is about
Pasadena that like there's a few areas
of La that kind of are underappreciated
if you will yeah I think pasaden is one
of them like Pasad is yeah absolutely
you know what I'm saying this is uh yeah
we for sure we underrated but um and
like people don't understand it also get
slept on and we just you know what I'm
saying we had to turn up and we just
never turned down you know what I'm
saying to get our respect and and well I
think most people go to Pasadena and
they go to either the rosebowl or they
go and they get food cuz they got that
street that's got all the restaurants
but it it does get active over they was
yeah they was looking at us like you
know I don't know what Hollywood or some
[__] but I mean and it's a nice area you
get tricked if you come over there for
sure you know what I'm say you thinking
you you safe in the good little area and
start going up but yeah that was the
that was the main thing probably get
tricked by just the surroundings yeah
but the individuals in their
cities vicious I feel like anywhere in
La you get tricked they got hoods
everywhere they got I didn't realize
some some spots you know you feel the
presence of of danger you know what I'm
saying like you don't really feel that
in Pasadena what I'm saying even now
right now feel [__] feel like I'm in
[__] West coina or something I was
going say when you got out you had to
probably be like damn this [__] changed
Big Time Y A lot of people in the hood
that's not even from the hood basically
all the homies they a lot of people
moved out cuz the [__] inflation just
it's crazy you know what I'm saying I
was looking I was looking at houses I
was looking at houses over there it's
crazy yeah you got to move like it's y
yeah we we going to change that we going
to get to these millions and these
billions I'mma B the whole Hood I love
it man